me parece que este vídeo te va a parecer
bien emocionante porque hasta ahorita
solo he estado hablando en términos muy
abstractos y he dibujado cajitas para
representar las hojas de balance pero en
esta ocasión te traigo una hoja de
balance real del banco de la reserva
federal de eeuu antes de que empezara el
lío del 2007 para que podamos ver cómo
es una hoja de balance de un banco
federal así en una situación normal
después si quieres en siguientes vídeos
vamos a compararlos pues con otras hojas
de balance para ver que han hecho en
otras situaciones para lograr que los
bancos permanezcan siendo líquidos y
permanezcan siendo solventes para poder
darles su dinero a sus clientes va a
estar padre así podemos pensar si lo que
han hecho está bien o mal se hizo una
interesante pero bueno esta es la hoja
de balances del banco de la reserva
federal de eeuu el 14 de febrero del
2007 ok entonces es antes de toda la
locura antes de que el banco empezará a
tomar acciones extremas para preservar
la liquidez de los bancos en fin estoy
aquí son sus activos para empezar es
interesante notar el numerito total en
activo ochocientos setenta y estos son
millones 871 mil
de dólares en activo veamos la
perspectiva general 871 mil millones en
activos déjame lo dibujo por acá en un
diagrama tradicional de cajita por acá
que del activo
este aquí es el activo
la suma de todo el activo es de esto de
acá es de 871 mil millones de dólares y
sabemos que el pasivo más del capital
ójala deben de sumar 800 71 mil millones
haber el pasivo total el pasivo total es
839 mil millones le voy a poner que es
840 mil entonces el pasivo lo voy a
poner con otro color el pasivo
840 mil millones redondeando tantito
sí creo que queda un poquito delgado
pero no es como que importe pero lo voy
a poner para que se vea bonito
entonces el pasivo es 840
840 mil millones va y lo que sobra debe
de ser capital verdad activo menos
pasivo o sea lo que tienes menos lo que
debes
después lo que te queda bueno lo que le
queda a los dueños del banco de la
reserva federal pero hay que tomarlos
con cuidado no son como los dueños de
una empresa más bien actúan como partes
interesadas
entonces lo que queda es el capital que
más o menos debe de ser como 31 mil
millones 31 mil millones vamos a
confirmarlo viendo la hoja de balance
y si aquí tenemos que el capital total
es de 31 mil millones vale hasta ahorita
si se parece mucho a lo que hemos estado
haciendo con las cajitas de la reserva
federal pero vamos a verlo más
profundamente para ver si encontramos
algo padre de qué platicar sabes con un
poco de suerte a lo mejor ya podemos
entender todo lo que dice o sea a todos
los renglones pero vamos a enfocarnos
por el momento en el activo entonces el
activo es nada más esta parte
ok pues vamos a ver qué dice esto es 11
mil millones en certificados de oro es
decir que tiene propiedad de cierto oro
déjame ver si tiene oro por otro lado a
ver no aquí dice moneda mil millones
pero todo esto son cachos chiquitos
verdad esto de la cuenta certificada de
retiros especiales no sé qué sea pero
igual es muy chiquito comparado con el
gran país de los 817 mil millones en
activo
vaya es una nimiedad acá tenemos una
porción bien grande sabes creo que estos
11.000 millones es oro real porque no
veo oro por ninguna otra parte entonces
creo que si combinas bueno
aproximadamente porque esta cosa de aquí
no sé que sea pero si combinas esto con
esto dice que la
federal porque no que oro por ninguna
otra parte pues si dice que el banco de
la reserva tiene como 12 mil millones en
oro que en realidad es muy poquito
comparado con el tamaño total de la hoja
de balance la gran parte
esto de acá déjame le pongo otro color
como morado son valores contratos de
recompra y préstamos 800 800 8000 casi
800 9000 millones de dólares es una
parte grandísima de la hoja de balance
de todos los 871 mil millones son 800
8000 millones en el dibujo le
correspondería como esta porción
bueno tal vez un poquito menos hay
valores vamos a chequear qué tipo de
valores tiene el banco de la reserva a
ver aquí los separaron esos 800 8.000
millones están dados por estas cosas que
estas de acá
la mayoría de estos son préstamos a la
tesorería de eeuu y dice que son
billetes notas y bonos ok deja explico
tantito un billete de tesorería es
esencialmente una deuda del gobierno por
un año o menos es un préstamo al
gobierno que vence en un año o tres
meses
notas y bonos son préstamos a la
tesorería a mayor plazo las notas son a
diez años y los bonos son a más de diez
años después tenemos bonos indexados por
inflación y luego voy a hacer un vídeo
de todo eso básicamente pues son valores
indexados por inflación y eso te permite
compensar el riesgo por la inflación
pero bueno hasta está de más decir que
en la perspectiva general 871 mil
millones de dólares son valores
gubernamentales préstamos al gobierno
federal déjame dibujarlo es un cacho
bien bien grande de más o menos como de
este tamaño todo estos son valores
gubernamentales pues casi todo lo que
tiene el banco de las reservas son
valores gubernamentales lo cual coincide
con lo que hemos platicado
hasta acá y lo que está interesante es
justo de lo que acabamos de hablar
contratos de recompra 30.000 millones en
contratos de recompra y bueno no estoy
totalmente seguro pero creo que estos se
obtuvieron porque alguien vino llegó a
la ventanilla de descuento y pidió
prestado al banco federal buenos nuevos
sólo una persona varias vinieron y
pidieron prestado al banco federal como
garantía dejaron algunos valores
gubernamentales pero como sabemos por la
forma en la que funcionan los contratos
de recompra es que le vendieron sus
valores al banco federal y luego se
comprometieron a volverlos a comprar
busque trabalenguas pero la cosa es que
estos contratos de recompra están
incluidos en estos valores acá porque no
son sólo contratos verdad probablemente
son valores gubernamentales o tal vez
algunos otros activos de alta calidad y
de bajo riesgo después voy a hablar un
poco acerca de como el banco federal ha
bajado sus exigencias acerca del tipo de
cosas que acepte en garantía o vaya del
tipo de activos que acepta en los
contratos de recompra bueno regresando a
la hoja son como 30 mil millones de
dólares y mira acá hay una pista de qué
se tratan los contratos de recompra
porque dice valores adquiridos en firme
sí verdad con estas no hay ningún
acuerdo de recompra la reserva federal
no firmé un contrato que lo obligue a
vender estos activos en otro momento
pero estas son transacciones de recompra
entonces funcionan más o menos como
garantía acá tienen préstamos firmes 49
1 fue súper poquito en este contexto
entonces la mayoría son valores
gubernamentales y hay un poquito en
contratos de recompra luego por aquí
tienen otros activos que nos separan tal
vez sea un poquito de oro no lo sé
instalaciones bancarias los edificios de
la reserva valen dos mil millones de
dólares seguro que si tienen doce bancos
y seguramente muchas otras propiedades
objetos en proceso de recolección la
verdad no sé que sea pero es muy poquito
comparado con lo grande con el activo
dominante del banco de la reserva que
actualmente son valores gubernamentales
pasemos al pasivo hasta cierto punto
puede ser más interesante a ver si lo
puedo leer neto total de las notas en
circulación del banco de la reserva
notas de la reserva federal a ver en
total son 700 69 mil millones de dólares
va entonces cuando hablaba de notas
pendientes es justo esto estas son notas
de la reserva
federal que han sido impresas entonces
estos son pasivos verdad porque pues el
banco federal las mandó imprimir y
entonces las metió al sistema como
moneda entonces alguien puede venir en
algún momento decir hey sabes que viene
por el valor que estas cosas representan
y eso es un concepto abstracto pero vaya
a aproximadamente setecientos y tantos
mil de esto son notas pendientes es
dinero que el banco de la reserva
imprimió a ver por acá también tenemos
algunos contratos de recompra inverso
eso quiere decir que por alguna razón el
banco de la reserva es un contrato de
recompra para pedir prestado también
tiene un poquito de depósitos y en los
años pasados estos depósitos han
incrementado dramáticamente pero aquí
son 22 mil millones de dólares estos son
depósitos que los bancos realmente
tienen en el banco de la reserva federal
la tesorería de eeuu también tiene algo
depositado en instituciones depositarias
eso es 17 mil millones y de hecho es así
la forma en la cual el banco de la
reserva paga sus gastos
la gente hace ciertos depósitos en el
banco de la reserva entonces supongamos
que estos de aquí son los depósitos de
los bancos no es tanto es 17 mil
millones
y esto podrían ser depósitos de los
bancos miembros pero el banco de la
reserva no paga interés en estos
depósitos no pagan interés en estos
depósitos entonces luego pueden tomarlos
e ir a comprar otro tipo de valores y
entonces ganan de ahí intereses
básicamente ganan intereses gratis y así
es como pueden financiar sus operaciones
claro qué pasa si sobra pues si sobra si
regresa al congreso no es como que
puedan decir un museo fiesta en el banco
central no no no bueno finalmente esto
no sé que sea igual es bien poquito
prácticamente no es nada pero la mayor
parte es dinero que ha sido impreso uno
de los mayores pasivos del banco de la
reserva un poquito de depósitos de las
instituciones depositarias y también la
asesoría de eeuu tiene un poquito de
dinero ahí y todo lo que resta debe de
ser capital en fin nada más quería
mostrarte que está bien padre esto de
que podamos ver la hoja de balance de un
banco de reserva federal seguro si
buscas en google puedes encontrar muchas
más lo que está más padre es que ahora
además puedes analizarlas ya tienes las
herramientas para entender más o menos
que dicen pero todavía más aún puedes
ver todos de ellas y comparar cuáles son
las nuevas acciones que ha realizado el
gobierno de eeuu
favorito